today i'm getting a phd from hustler
university also known as hustler versity
by those of us with the grind set it was
created by this guy i'm talk to you you
think you're smart i bought this coin
and it's going up you could have bought
any coin and it went up in the last year
the matrix was broken hustlers
university is the greatest thing that
exists on the face of the planet for
people who are trying to escape the
matrix become hostage university welcome
to the metaverse inject it into your
brain you can skip university you can
buy my program and i guarantee you you
will know everything you need to know
have you ever seen a college professor
with an s63 and a mclaren and a lambo
and aston martin standing next to a
porsche no you never seen any of this i
know how to make
now if you're wondering why i'm
enrolling in a college that looks like
it was started by the son of mr
worldwide it's actually quite simple
hustle versity was started by andrew
tate a guy that basically no one knew
about until six months ago and is now
somehow more searched than mr beast
kanye west or most shocking of all even
the island boys who i know i thought
would have a career forever but such are
the tides of fame i suppose and i guess
the real question is how did this happen
and why well andrew attributes his
meteoric success to a change in business
strategy i put together a particular
strategy about six months ago because i
decided to step up my overall exposure
because of a new product i launched i
run an online school that teaches people
how to make money online i changed my
approach towards social media and i
ended up absolutely everywhere now if
you're wondering what business strategy
that is or even what business this guy's
in turns out he's one of these male
success gurus who will be your surrogate
father essentially for a fee and the
program he runs is called hustle versity
where he teaches you how to make fast
money if you'll only pay fifty dollars a
month and one of these fast money
methods turns out to be selling hustle
adversity to new people by posting clips
of him andrew tate and because of this
it kind of created this pyramid scheme
where there was a flood of tick-tock
videos and bias reviews saying that
andrew tate is the one true savior that
will save you from poverty he's
basically morpheus from the matrix and
that's not even me calling him that he
calls himself that i get called morpheus
along we are living inside of the matrix
and i am morpheus
he says he wants to wake you from your
mental prisons all by selling you a
program that sounds like what high
school dropouts used to put as their
education status on facebook attended
the school of hard knocks and graduated
hustleversity with a phd wait you're a
doctor no that's the pimping ho's degree
which is something by the way i didn't
make up it's a course that andrew tate
himself sells but i don't think you want
to take advice from someone who's in the
middle of a human
investigation and that's not even to
mention accusations of beating women or
him allegedly admitting that one of his
businesses was quote a total scam but
none of this has stopped over a hundred
thousand people from signing up for
hustle versity which at 50 bucks a month
nets him five million dollars a month
despite it being a repackaged version of
the same male guru griff that we've seen
over a hundred times like tom vu john
crostani dan lok grant cardone need i go
on what's the difference with tate see
despite his alleged criminality toxicity
psychopathy andrew does have one
undeniable skill that seems to be
responsible for most or all of his
success so far he's just really
entertaining i hate everyone equally
don't come at me and call me sexist or
racist or any of these things i hate
everyone i don't care if you're black
white straight gay man and woman i hate
you anyway do know how to administer cpr
however i will not administer cpr unless
you're a hot female if you're some fat
dude and you just had a heart attack and
i don't really know you
is that a lady building you a new back
and rearrange your bones why is it been
missing for around four hours straight
bro i have a lot of muscle it's it's
painful to carry around it's a two-hour
massage you see guys modern influencers
are slowly learning that we live in a
post-consequence world with people like
jake paul running around just serially
scamming people and nothing happening to
them
people are starting to realize that the
only real currency is attention like the
worst thing that's going to happen to
you is not that you go to jail the worst
thing that's going to happen to you is
you become irrelevant and this is what
separates andrew tate from a lot of the
fake gurus i've covered in the past and
makes him much more effective and maybe
dangerous at what he does and in that
way he's got more in common with someone
like alex jones we're gonna beat your
ass you just get that through your
stinking traitorous heads then he does
with someone like dan lok or grant
cardone both jones and tate operate sort
of on this playbook where entertainment
is king they say a bunch of outlandish
statements that builds attention and
then once they're the crazy guy all they
have to do is say a few basic things
that everyone agrees with and then their
audience suddenly thinks they're a
genius i mean everyone has seen this
with alex jones right you have modern
philosopher joe rogan seemingly saying
that he predicts everything alex is
right about far more than he's wrong
when in reality alex jones is predicting
everything sort of all the time so of
course he's going to be right some of
the time and it's sort of the same with
tate he says so much like in one segment
he'll say something outlandish like men
should be able to cheat on women but it
doesn't work the other way around
because that's disgusting let's not
pretend that male loyalty and female
loyalty are the same thing but loyalty
is loyalty
but they're not the same thing are they
however i would not see my infidelity as
nearly anywhere near even one percent as
disgusting as female infidelity and he
knows that's going to get him clicks and
piss people off but then we'll say in a
segment right after i believe in true
love between a man and a woman i believe
there should be more love i think
relationships are a beautiful thing i
think that the synergy between men and
women are a beautiful thing if they are
correctly collaborated i think that
that's what makes society function i
think that's what makes the world
function i think that many men and women
falling in love and having children and
having families are very very beautiful
things well who doesn't agree with that
and i'll talk to like men's issues he'll
talk about how lonely men are
most men are absolutely not really
invisible this is the truth about
masculinity right it's very easy for
women to sit here and complain about the
top two percent of men because i met
with dealt with this guy's arrogant blah
blah blah blah most men don't even
[ __ ] exist they send 10 000 dm's and
never even get read let alone replied to
and so this makes it so that the many
people who are trying to say ah andrew's
just crazy they don't see the full con
that he's running because the crazy is
only half of the game because eventually
people hear the other half the basic
stuff that's obvious and go well he's
not totally crazy and people just
eventually kind of go down the tate
rabbit hole where they think you know
maybe i can leave the matrix and get
girls jets and bugattis maybe i just
need to become financially free how do i
do it who's looking out for me and
that's where hustle versity enters the
picture
and look i know we just covered a lot
right but to understand this next part
to understand hustle versity it requires
a deep understanding of andrew tate's
appeal so we can see why hustle
adversity is on the one hand so popular
despite being so bad
because otherwise this whole video is
anticlimactic and confusing because when
i first joined hustleversity i thought
it's got to be different right
to have this many people paying every
month
they have to have things that you just
can't learn for free right right once
again i'm disappointed because i joined
this month and have been going through
the classes which is basically all of
the same boring topics all of these guys
teach about making money it's all the
most surface level stuff he assigns a
so-called professor to each skill and
all of this all takes place inside of
discord servers and so in these chat
rooms where your instructors have a
fraction of the charisma of tate you're
supposed to commit yourself to these
skill sets which are super surface level
because of course this all appeals to
the lowest common denominator men who
think answers can come from tick tock
videos and this is where it starts to
hit you as you're scrolling through
discord threads that this kind of was
all a big bait and switch i mean think
about it you've been told you're gonna
escape the matrix you're gonna take the
red pill but what you end up doing in
this course is sort of learning how to
run an amazon side hustle for jeff bezos
like no offense you're not breaking the
matrix you work for the richest guy in
the world like imagine morpheus gives
neo the red pill and says hey have you
ever day traded before
it doesn't stop there either like you've
been told you're going to be rich right
i guarantee you will make money with
this system hold on tight we're about to
get rich but hustlers university sort of
changes the rules and definitions once
you're inside like they have this cash
quadrant of time and cash where you're
either time poor or cash poor
time rich cash for
cash rich time you get the idea
and what they define
cash rich as is very telling they define
it as having five thousand dollars which
by that definition guys i'm proud to say
i'm cash rich now guys look having five
thousand dollars is great
but you ain't rich right the lifestyle
we've been sold on here
is exotic bugattis not extra starbucks
biscottis i mean am i crazy here like i
feel like most people who join this
discord want olive lamborghinis and
they're sort of getting olive garden
fettuccine and this weird disconnect is
everywhere where andrew tate is
practically screaming how great hustlers
university is on the one hand hofstra's
university is the greatest thing that
exists on the face of the planet for
people who are trying to escape the
matrix and yet if you look at their own
success screenshots that they provide
their students are getting at best like
very part-time income like their
screenshots of 400 a month maybe 2 000 a
month and those are the examples they
chose which i'm not knocking the people
who are doing this like good for them
but unless you consider being cash rich
having five thousand dollars total in
your bank account then this course
doesn't seem to be getting people rich
it just teaches lost guys extremely
basic skills that are free to learn but
charges them 50 a month for it so they
can feel like they're escaping the
matrix by working for jeff bezos and
this all brings us kind of back to the
real reason for the success of hustlers
university which is of course tate
himself but the irony is that once you
join the university you barely see tate
at all he claims to be teaching the
secrets to modern wealth creation but
the reality is from what i saw he was
too busy marketing to actually be
present in the discord and instead you
just had all these random people
teaching you like e-commerce or
freelancing or copywriting and investing
and this is kind of one of the reasons
that i struggled to get good screenshots
to show you guys from inside the course
because it was so boring and bland and
that's why i decided to finally cancel
my plans to become cash rich and that's
when i found out about the last trick
tate uses to get you to stay anyone who
messes this up annoys a professor
doesn't renew their subscription their
card cancels anything stupid then you're
gonna regret it for a very long time
because there's simply nowhere else to
go that's right they tell you there's
nowhere else to go besides hustlers
university this is the only place where
you're gonna learn not to be broke and
even the people who want to be part of
it and simply don't have the money tate
has told them that there's no second
chances they're gonna go back in the
matrix if they miss a single payment i
had to unsubscribe to get my mother a
birthday present but i resubscribed the
next month i don't believe that i don't
believe you and i also think if you were
a member of of hustlers university for a
month and you didn't make enough money
to buy your mother a birthday present
you [ __ ] up so you're probably gonna
end up kicked out like their two
responses are that's not true and even
if it is it's your fault anyways which i
find amazing it couldn't be the program
right guys and you have to understand
that for the people actually in the
course they're like deathly afraid of
missing a payment because they've been
told that if they do guess where they're
going that's right straight back in the
matrix in jail they call it and you'll
see we have people in jail so people who
uh don't renew we don't kick you out we
put you in the jail and you sit there in
your cell and you have no access to the
money-making information and we just
flood you with all the endless wins
every time someone wins we show you i
mean andrew tate hasn't reinvented
anything he's just doing it more
successfully than a lot of fake gurus
have in a while but the result is the
same as ever where the real person
getting rich truly rich is andrew tate
you're broke you're [ __ ] poor